you write about some green lights being
engineered and some being mystical
which I love the difference of that
what's the difference of the engineered
green lights and the mystical such a
cool word mystical yeah well the
engineered ones have reason and the
physical ones have rhyme
yeah you know Life's a mystery going
forward but it's a science looking back
I prepared I've had ideas written
headlines and had goals and
athlete gets in shape for an event and I
get in shape for a role I read I study I
work I prepare
and I go I'm prepared and I behave and I
do it
and I look at it I go yes
that's what I wanted to do
it's engineered green light
it's it's it's it's
a it's a it's a conscious delayed
gratification
it's that if I do it today
that pragmatic head down
believe there's no Cloud out there but
then I trust that there is one out there
if I do keep my head down to do it I'll
get that to that dream
we can engineer those habit
work ethic prep expertise education
and the mystical ones though
don't make any sense they're not
supposed to make sense they only make
sense after
right when they happen you backlog and
you connect the dots with how they got
there that that that that that red light
you ran into that made you 30 seconds
later to
get to the restaurant
as you walked in she walked out
and he went good morning and she went
good morning
and yeah
too much later you're dating
two years later you're married
you after that you've got a family and
now you're sitting here 40 years later
going
I love you look at what we've built
and you go back and go
what if I wouldn't hit that red light
those 30 seconds you know made all the
difference and so strange that this life
is this way yeah and that's just rhyme I
mean we can't really add that up yeah
it's a science when you look back you
you see you know why it was that
you were
you were upset and
ticked off that you had to pick up the
kids toys before we left and they were
supposed to pick them up and therefore
you were late for the thing that maybe
you ran into and you and you ran into
the person that was walking in the
office that the guy that you did the
interview that's the guy you were
looking for the job you wanted and you
caught him because you were in the
elevator with him and that 90 seconds on
that elevator what got you that job that
led you let you do what you want to do I
mean
the significance is there but we have to
I think what we also got to watch is
again in that balance
what do we change because do we just
chased the engineering we miss Magic
if we just chase the mystical
we find ourselves caught up in trying to
give meaning to the Lego set that was on
the floor that the kids didn't pick up
that and what color was it and and why
did I walk out that that door and see
almost up on the Legos but if I'd gone
out the other door I used to go out if I
would have gone there I would have got
there early and wouldn't run into the
the boss and the the so you can start to
give too much
meaning on that as well I think we can
give significance in too many places and
all of a sudden
I think we've all been there where
you're seeing art in every single thing
oh man that can be paralyzing
it's like it's hard to leave a room if
everything's significant you know or if
everything's a sign
you know how much of success in life do
you think is uh engineered and how much
is Mystical I and how much does it
differ from person to person because I
for me personally maybe I enjoy it maybe
I'm genetically built that way but I
exist more in the mystical so I don't
make plans I travel last summer in
Ukraine with no plan I just went there
no plan
I didn't know how I'm going to meet the
president of the country I didn't know
anybody and so
there's no plan there's no clear thing
you're just roaming around and that's
how I've existed in life and it there's
something about giving yourself over to
the flow of nature that I just enjoy it
makes life so much fun
it's
awesome when you can do it did you
engineer though I'm going to put myself
in the place when you got on the plane
to go to the destination that was an
engineered choice
yes
and maybe I'll meet and I'll run into
and I can work up a sit down with
so the engineering Choice was putting
your shoes on preferably get you know I
always say this the hardest part about
going to gyms putting your shoes on
right so to getting on the plane that
was an engineered thought with the goal
in mind but I don't know how I'm going
to do it
the choice yeah putting the shoes on
yeah
but there's not a clear it's a fog what
happens after the shoe is gone
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna take that leap so I
I wonder how much uh
for people who are successful in this
world and finding what makes them uh
truly happy and fulfilled how much of it
is engineer how much is this mystical
how much was it for you well I'll say
this like an hour at winter right
about green lights which is basically
the last 40 years of my life I thought
that 85 90 of my successes were going to
be
obviously engineered
or I could see the signs it's all the
habits here's what I did yep that add up
got the solution got the conclusion
I was
very surprised when I noticed it was
probably less than 50 percent
and that most of the real successes of
mine for when I
trusted
when I trusted
that I didn't have to Define it that I
only trusted that I didn't have to go
what's the measurement
what's the score
what lead this leads to what what's next
um
and I for me
that that's still there's still a
challenge for me
daily
now is to trust and not be because I can
be I could I think I can be overly
practical
and I think I can over over compensate
and miss out on Magic
because I'm still
going
wait but do you are we given enough am I
are we giving enough the measure and
credit to actuality
are we or am I giving enough credit to
this is this these are the steps to take
and and and and and this is reality
I I think
I'm reminded
when I when I trust because that going
with the Mystic just to put yourself on
the plane was the engineer be getting
there and as you say you've seen you say
you roll in that mystical it takes a lot
of trust yeah
trust in the inevitable Amen on that to
but not knowing where it actually ends
you it's it's a feeling more than um
uh I don't think it's a Clear Vision
right
it's kind of like a feeling that guides
you towards uh
towards a place with with uh
without a clear name without clear
characteristics it just kind of pulls
you there
where do you get that courage and Trust
to go with your gut your your feeling
and is there
for instance three days later you sit
down is there if you did if that if that
doesn't happen
is there a sense
a week two weeks later now when you come
back
To America that like ah
I failed
sort of uh looking back to try to
analyze what went right we went wrong
that kind of thing
uh yeah that engine is always there
but I think what pulls me forward in
life what makes me really grateful and
fulfilled is noticing the thing you
mentioned noticing the magic
and kind of going towards it
sort of just sitting back
um both in tragedy and then Triumph so
in war there's a lot of tragedy but
there's somehow
uh one of the things you see in in war
this is the first war I've experienced
and seen seen the front
is the loss that people lose their homes
and all this kind of stuff
the thing that rises from that is the
love for each other
so they uh the people I've spoken with
don't give a damn about the home don't
give a damn about that on farms and the
animals they lost don't don't give a
damn about
um having to move and all this kind of
stuff as long as the family's still
there as long as the people they love
are still there and it's like
that's the there's this Melancholy smile
they have on their face
like yeah this world is full of [__]
it's full of tragedy
but life is [__] awesome and that and
you just notice that in in little ways
everywhere
you just sit back and yeah notice the
magic and then I want more of that
and just kind of follow along with a
little ant yeah
keep noticing that kind of thing but uh
I don't know I I hope you know what I
what I think it is is other people
notice that you're the kind of person
that notices it uh and they're like I
want to hang out with that person he
seems all right like he seems one of the
uh one of the good ones one of the good
hands do you have uh um
any certain
non-negotiable structure before that
freedom to go with the feeling
I think so there's a set of principles
I'll just uh basically Integrity of
being uh good to other people
like whatever that means for me there's
specific things like I I'm really into
loyalty
Above the Law right there's a kind of
like there's a circle of friends I have
and that means everything
um
there's just a Basics deep kindness
towards others
uh empathy empathy towards people that
other
that others might label as
um
even evil I have that kind of empathy I
believe all of us have the capacity to
do good and evil
so I just kind of see everybody as
little babies that grow up in different
conditions and so some do evil some do
good
and there's yeah there's there's all
kinds out there
uh principles
I love the dynamic routine the different
humans and their full diversity I love
the the dynamic between the masculine
the feminine enjoy it the dance of it
yeah yeah
so you have a constitution with which
you embark
you do too chasing yes I hope so
um
and then yeah for me I'd like to
it's inspiring to hear
someone like yourself go I go and I just
land and I just go I'm gonna feel it
um I can go back and go yeah my greatest
truth I've crossed my greatest successes
in my life were when
I trusted that and go I took a one-way
ticket
Amazon Africa
yeah and those were spiritual
and very pragmatic because they led to
dealing with with
succeeding in other in other ways that
are more pragmatic a hundred percent and
gave much more meaning
to those things
but that's that's to be able to
go out and and say that's how you do you
have family I really want to get married
and have kids but I I'm not married and
don't have kids yet okay so actually one
of the nice things about that is you can
take bigger risks
so while I'm not married and don't have
kids I feel I owe it to myself to take
just to go go to the Amazon that is
throw that backpack on and one-way
ticket yeah yeah that does get harder to
do yeah
um
I missed that
sometimes
the
the whim
a song that comes on you know
yeah where's that guy from
oh they're from the place that I want to
go that had a dream about I'll go there
when we dig it what I gotta do I'll get
a couple shots okay go that that
there's that that was that was fun how
did I do that let's get up and go you're
free yeah and go when are you back when
I
when I get there yeah it's a beautiful
beautiful thing maybe never yeah yeah my
yeah
you'll be coming to visit me in this new
place maybe yeah